I was just really scared
I didn't know what was happening I
wasn't told any alternative of pain
relief until I got to the hospital
Emma was about to endure the most
agonizing pain of her life struggling to
deliver a baby without any gas and air
pain relief it was really bad I've never
experienced that type of pain before
well had that type but without the pain
relief that's really excruciating and I
think if he was my first baby that would
really put me off of having another one
it was hard to breathe through it
because it was taking my breath away
it's like really bad Emma's Hospital
suspended gas and air because of safety
fears but nobody had warned her it was
just the pain
um he's not my first baby and so my
previous labors all I've had is gas near
and it helped with the contractions the
pushing part of things as well
I know I really struggled
we've lived without without it the gas
and air canisters were all in the
corridors all on view and it's just
there and you can't have any how do you
feel you've been treated as an expectant
mother
um not very well the the
someone should have phoned us up and
said look this has happened at the
hospital we have to and suspend our
snare and explain why that way not
reading it on Facebook the days before
Kingston's birth were anxious and
stressful far from ideal for an
expectant mother Emma says she has
nothing but praise for the nurses
midwives and other health workers who
delivered her baby safely but she said
she had to endure seven hours of Agony
without ever being told why she couldn't
have access to gas and air she says the
treatment is simply shocking
Ipswich hospital has resumed gas and air
after improving the ventilation in its
maternity units it says it had to take
the action to ensure the safety of Staff
while completely safe for mothers and
babies prolonged exposure to gas and air
has been linked to infertility and other
serious harms the health and safety
executive have given guidance to
hospital trusts on this and it was some
time ago there definitely seems to have
been a domino effect with one or two
units realizing they have a problem and
then other units beginning to sit up and
take notice I think it is a symptom of a
lack of investment in maternity services
and it certainly seems to give the
message to staff that their health and
safety is not a priority NHS England has
warned hospitals that gas and air should
only be stopped as a last resort
that will be of little Comfort to
anxious mothers ahead of one of the most
important moments in their lives Ashish
Joshi Sky News in Ipswich